I I remember when we first came to La my
mom was like there's two things that I
want you to think about like being a kid
in in Hollywood one is the second it's
not fun we pack up our stuff and we go
home that's it it has to be fun because
you're a kid and you should be having
fun and so if this isn't fun then we
have to we like forget it yeah I was
like okay then the second thing is she
said I want you to look at your career
as like that toy that you want from
Santa so bad when you're a kid and then
you get it and there's two types of kids
one will take the toy and break it the
first day and smash it into pieces even
though it was the thing that they wanted
more than anything in the world or you
have the kid who like packs up their
room when they're getting ready to go to
college and that toy is still in a box
somewhere because they took such good
care of it right that they loved it
forever and she was like you can look at
your career and you can take care of it
either way that you want and she's like
but I really hope that you'll choose the
kid who is something really proud to
still hold on to like